so there's actually a four-step method
for teaching any kid any skill and we'd
seem to be ignoring steps two and three
and expecting them to go from step one
to step four step one is
there's so many uh
interesting and compelling ideas
in the book and we obviously don't have
time to
talk about all of them but there's a
couple that i would like to highlight
not the least of which is this idea of
fending
right so explain it
yeah you know it's funny rich since the
book came out
people have really called out that term
they're like well no you're usually like
wait what does that mean exactly so
i know defending
fending for yourself so all i can say is
this term was such a part of my
childhood my parents must have
constantly been talking about when
you're grown up you fend for yourself
because to me it's a word that we use
like any other word um
fending is this visceral
animal kingdom
truth that applies to us humans
we're mammals
can we posit that right we're mammals
we have jackets and cell phones right we
wear fancy watches and sneakers and
we are mammals and like any mammal
parent
we have to know
for our own biological determination
like we have to know our genes will get
passed on how do our jeans get passed on
if our kids can fend for themselves out
in the world without us like any mammal
parent we need to know that so fending
comprises those small set of things
small basic fundamental set of things a
human's got to be able to do in order to
take care of business take care of their
body
their belongings their bills
adulting is you know
you are more or less responsible for
yourself
doesn't mean you go it alone but more or
less your response to yourself childhood
someone else was more or less
responsible for you assuming your
parents could show up and did show up to
look after you
so fending is that i'm responsible for
myself more or less it's the basics
which is why it's only you know chapter
two right out of 13. right and i i feel
like
parents understand this intellectually
but in practice we end up kind of doing
it ourselves for them because it's just
easier that's right and we believe or we
delude ourselves into thinking that by
doing it while they're observing it that
they're learning how to do it but
actually you're handicapping them and
creating a dependency
so there's actually a four-step method
for teaching any kid any skill and we'd
seem to be ignoring steps
two and three and expecting them to go
from step one to step four step one is
we do it for them step two is we do it
with them step three is we flip the
tables and watch them do it but we're
still there step four is they can do it
when we're over parenting we're in step
one maybe step two we're there handling
fixing of course we can do it rich
we've been fourth graders right it's
their turn right
okay we're suppose but i'm late you know
i got to get to work i know you know
this kid can't tie his shoes and he's
like i gotta get going then you have an
eight-year-old who can't tie their shoes
or i'm too busy to teach them to cross
the streets then you have a 12 year old
who's never crossed the street by
themselves so you can see the ways in
which we undermine we have to parent
with a little bit more patience and for
the longer term i like to tell folks
like it or not and nobody likes it we'll
be dead one day
we have to raise our kids so that when
we are gone and hopefully well before
they've got it
they can look after us in our old age
obviously there's a spectrum between
helicopter parenting and like kind of
you know
flagrant disregard yeah
so you know where is the line how do we
find that sweet spot or where is that
line like identifying that and i i
suspect it's going to be different with
every kid yes
sure it's different for every kid just
as you've got your four and you're going
to pay attention to their needs and
proclivities and whatnot and and do
things slightly differently every kid is
different and yet
there are fundamental things so i'm
going to use the sport of bowling as a
visual metaphor
for where you draw the line or where you
put up the bumpers okay when somebody is
brand new at bowling
um you raise the bumpers so that their
ball doesn't go into the gutter so they
have some chance of hitting a pin
and not just flailing not just
right
when we over parent it's as if we're
taking those bumpers and instead of just
putting them at the edge where the
gutters are which the parenting
equivalent of is make sure your kid
doesn't drown makes you sure your kid
doesn't walk into traffic okay
life or death we're supposed to protect
them from dying okay
and let them have the experiences of
life let that ball meander and maybe
it'll hit a pin or two and maybe over
time it'll hit three and then five and
then ten okay we bring the bumpers or
the guardrails or whatever they're
called clearly i'm not actually a bowler
we bring them in so narrowly and if you
can see me now i'm holding my hands at
the width of a bowling ball so that the
kid just throws the ball and we are
right there making sure it goes right
down
and they miss out on the experiences
that will teach them how to throw the
ball straighter and
more confidently and with greater heft
okay that's
that's the visual
okay we're also supposed to be delighted
by them learning a skill
so over sometimes parents say when do
you when do you start whereas the line
is a question i get when do you start
giving them independence i also get
and i say back why did you stop when
they were learning to walk you didn't
over parent
they fell you didn't yell get up we're
embarrassed by you you know your older
brother walked tuner right we don't do
that we take pictures and clap and laugh
and
video grandma
if we over parented in that moment it
would be to get behind them on their on
our knees and put our hands under their
armpits and slowly walk them forward
toward the other parent and then we'd
get to the end and say we walked right
no you didn't like you did the kid
didn't if they forever fall into your
strong body they haven't learned the
skill
so the right line there is remove the
objects on which they can impale
themselves if they fall while learning
to walk make sure the environment is
safe
but let them go and do it yeah
yeah over time of course this leads to
the messaging is
you're not capable of doing it yourself
that's what i'm helping that's right and
that that really is pernicious it is and
it messes with their developing brain
and their sense of self
and it's hard to correlate a parenting
style with anything because parenting is
24 7 and it's hard to have a control
group of children who
weren't parented that way right but
people who study this
have correlated the over-involved
parenting style with higher rates of
anxiety and depression in children
because
we are undermining the development of
agency which is the sense i can
and the development of resilience that
comes from you know things not going
great and you discover i can cope
we undermine the development of these
things which really are the foundations
of a healthy life
when we over help
[Music]
you